Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Bist du vom einunddreißig C drei wieder erwacht?
Ich bin mitten im Prozess.
Neues Jahr, neues Glück, neues Logbuch Netzpolitik. Oh, es hat sich fast gereimt. Ähm ihr hört schon an unseren, na, so fast.
Glück und Netzpolitik, meinst du?
Genau, ja.
Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Ich fast gereimt.
Mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Der Schüttel rein, der Schüttel rein, der reimt sich nicht, der reimt sich nicht
Ja und ich bin auch so ein bisschen also ich bin irgendwie also ich hab den Kongress noch nicht so komplett überlebt um ehrlich zu sein. Also es waren jetzt grade mal irgendwie zehn Tage das ist zu wenig.
Zur vollständigen Erholung.
Ja, genau, also drei Tage brauchte ich einfach so rein zur physikalischen Regenerierung, physischen, physisch, physikalischen Regenerierung. So, bis einfach mal, wie die Zellen wieder aufgeladen waren,
Ja und jetzt ist ja noch äh noch einiges nachzuholen so inhaltlich und.
Das ganze Programm noch gucken.
Sowas das ganze Programm noch,
muss ich irgendwie erzählen lassen und so weiter. Aber wir werden uns hier heute auch nochmal ein bisschen äh erzählen lassen, nicht wahr? Von uns gegenseitig.
Ja ne, der Kongress, der schlaucht halt schon jedes Jahr mehr, als man sich vornimmt oder äh als man damit gerechnet hat, ne?
Genau, aber das äh ist war die Reise auf jeden Fall wert. So viel kann man schon mal vorwegnehmen.
Ja und dieses Jahr war ja besonders besonders günstige äh Lage mit den mit den freien Tagen, ne? Weil man ist ja quasi
den einunddreißigsten hat man ja eh sich freigenommen und dann war, war ja der erste quasi, ne? Und dann musste man sich nur noch den zweiten frei nehmen, um im Prinzip bis zum Abend des vierten Januars
ähm durchgängig im Bett liegen und Kongressvideos schauen zu können und dann geht das ja.
Unter diesem Aspekt, da wird es noch gar nicht betrachtet.
Ja, du bist ja auch kein, du bist ja auch kein äh äh wie nennt man das.
Nine to Fiver.
Nine to Fiver, genau, kein, kein Sozialversicherungspflichtig, Beschäftigter, Nichtselbstständig, Nichtselbstständiger
äh nicht selbstständig heißt das, genau, in der Steuererklärung. Einkünfte aus nichtselbständiger Arbeit. Ich habe nämlich dann meine Steuererklärung gemacht, deswegen weiß ich das.
Ja da, da muss ich noch, da muss ich noch ran. Ja, nee, für Selbstständige macht das irgendwie alles nicht so einen großen Unterschied und ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte lieber so eine,
längere erste Woche, aber egal, wir wollen uns nicht beklagen, der Kongress war es auf jeden Fall wert und wir werden auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen äh intensiver einsteigen. Wir hatten ja auch ähm,
schöne Sendung, die leider, leider, leider bisher nur ein Audio vorliegt, die Videoaufzeichnung
hat es leider noch nicht ins Netz geschafft, aber ich hoffe, das wird nicht mehr sehr lange dauern
ist leider eine der letzten Aufzeichnungen, die dann nicht mehr veröffentlicht werden konnten, bevor das ganze Equipment in den Truck gepackt wurde und jetzt muss es alles erst mal aus dem Truck wieder ausgepackt werden, bevor sich da jemand verantwortungsvoll ransetzen kann.
Truck. Bisschen Aufnahmen wird im Truck gefahren, sagste?
Das Equipment des Videooperation Centers, wo die ganzen Aufnahmen draufliegen, die waren dann halt irgendwann eingetütet, aber noch nicht so richtig im Netz, also da muss man sozusagen nochmal das Schneidepersonal ran.
Wollte nur damit angeben, dass der CCC selbstverständlich äh über LKWs verfügt, mit denen äh.
Ja, also ich äh will keine Illusion an die Wand malen. Das ist noch nicht so, dass wir jetzt schon wirklich so komplette Rockstar äh Lastwagenzüge haben, wo dann so Wok und Knock draufsteht,
Aber wenn man sich diesen Kongress so anschaut, hat man so langsam den Eindruck, dass es darauf irgendwann noch mal hinauslaufen könnte.
Aber wollen wir jetzt erstmal mit den schlechten Nachrichten anfangen?
Ach ja.
Nicht, dass unsere Hörer hier verwöhnt werden.
Also, es war nicht alles gut. Es gab auch was Schlechtes und zwar äh ich weiß nicht, ob sie Nachrichten gelesen haben, aber in Frankreich gab's da so einen kleinen Zwischenfall.
Ja, gab's. Das stimmt.
Anschlag auf die Redaktion des äh Satiremagazines.
Genau.
Und äh es wird äh diskutiert, dass das wohl damit zusammenhängen könnte, dass sich die Redaktion von Charlie Epdo
grundsätzlich über alle Regionen dieser Welt lustig macht und es eventuell
ein paar Menschen gegeben haben könnte, denen das nicht gefallen hat, insbesondere, dass sie sich über
den Propheten Mohammed lustig gemacht haben und dass das dann letztendlich dazu führte dass,
Zwölf Redaktionsmitglieder in so einer Art Militäraktion ähm brutalst irgendwie getötet wurden.
Also ich glaube Redaktionsmitglieder waren's äh unterm Strich glaube ich nur vier
und dann halt andere Leute äh auch noch äh zu Kollateralschäden geworden, so von äh Reinigungskräften im Eingang und äh lustigerweise auch noch einem, also lustigerweise
habe ich mich gleich verplappert. Und äh unter anderem auch noch einem arabischstämmigen Polizisten, ja, der versucht hat, äh da,
Verteidigungslinie aufzubauen. Also es ist alles,
eine superscheiße Aktion und das ist alles richtig furchtbar und man mag da irgendwie gar nicht richtig drüber nachdenken. Die Empörung ist äh
groß. Ja, was natürlich äh niemanden davon abhält, die entsprechenden Maßnahmen zu fordern, die natürlich jetzt unbedingt zur Verhinderung von weiteren Terrortaten dieser Art und Weise absolut unerlässlich sind.
Vielleicht noch kurz ähm zur nicht-Netz-Politischen Einordnung, wenn das passiert in einer Zeit, weil weil du ja auch immer betonst, ne, dass wir ja hier für die, auch für die
Nachwelt äh dokumentieren. Das passiert in einer Zeit, zu der in Deutschland ähm große,
Ausländerfeindliche Demonstrationen stattfinden, ne? Wir haben irgendwie fünfstellige niedrige fünfstellige Anzahlen
islamfeindlicher Demonstranten in Dresden
die irgendwie unter diesen äh Label Pegida, Patriotische Europäer gegen die Islamisierung des Abendlandes.
Sich irgendwie mit den null Komma zwei Prozent Migrantenanteil in Sachsen auseinandersetzen.
Ja
Ja? Heute sehr schön äh auf Twitter gelesen. Kennst du äh Schrödinger als Ausländer?
Schrödingers Ausländer nimmt dir den Job unter Arbeitslosengeld gleichzeitig weg.
Ja also es ist wirklich äh absurd, was,
Da stattfindet, es ist irgendwie bitte ich die also ich meine islamfeindlich würde ich sie nicht nennen. Das ist halt einfach ausländerfeindlich.
Ja, Ausländerfeier, habe ich das, habe ich das äh.
Ja, na ja, ich meine, Islam ist da halt äh sozusagen jetzt grade die die Positionsfläche, aber,
Habt ihr einen schönen Blogartikel gelesen von jemanden, der ähm da sie sich ja immer so um das,
Abendland, ja, das sogenannte jüdisch-christliche Abendland, dem man in Deutschland eigentlich auch
gar nicht so richtig angehört hat jemals. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie so ihr Termen und dann hat sich mal irgendjemand äh mit einer Israelfahne so mitten in diesen Pegida-Pulk reingestellt
und äh,
natürlich dann auch gleich Flack bekommen und wurde dann sozusagen auch gleich aus dieser Demo rausgedrängt. Also so viel zur äh angeblichen Offenheit an der Stelle.
Na, das sind Ausländerfeinde, ja und zwar auch ziemlich strunz Dumme, ne. Muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen.
Ja, das ist strunzdummer, beziehungsweise halt auch einfach so, so, so, so Bürger, die einfach mal wieder den Schuss überhaupt nicht gehört haben und sich hier einfach von so einem Nazivolk instrumental äh instrumentalisieren lassen, das ist schon einfach bedrückend.
In Berlin gab's ja äh also auf Berlin kann man ja nach wie vor äh in in solchen Fragen zum Glück zählen. Da ist jetzt schon die zweite.
Also es gibt ja eine ganze IDA-Reihe, ne.
Die äh gehen ja überall hin,
In Köln haben sie dann den Dom ausgeschaltet als die äh Idioten da aufgelaufen sind und in Berlin waren es, ich glaube, fünfzig ähm,
Idioten, denen irgendwie schon mal so
hundert Pressefotografen gegenüber standen und fünftausend äh Gegendemonstranten äh ungefähr diese Region, ne, also und.
Ja
Da da kann man ja dann noch so ein bisschen hoffen.
Ja, also Dresden war wohl auch die einzige Stadt, wo es mir äh Demonstranten als Gegendemonstranten gab.
Ja da allerdings auch signifikant. Ja, wie gesagt, auch die sind ja Dresden ist leider in in der in der
in diesem Bereich der ausländerfeindlichkeit ja leider ähm seit jeher oder seit seit äh seit der Wende immer wieder ein trauriges äh Beispiel, ne?
Ja, aber zur Einordnung muss man vielleicht auch nochmal so diesen sonstigen äh globalen Kontext auch noch mit anführen. Ich meine, wir haben den,
eine eine Vielzahl an Konflikten und Kriegen
die sich eben unter anderem auch aus dieser Radikalisierung des Islams im Sinne von eben islamistischer Bewegung heraus ergibt, sprich islamischer Staat kämpft in Syrien und im Irak
und ähm,
Boko Haram hat irgendwie jetzt am vorgestern irgendwie auch mal soeben ein Dorf mit zweitausend Leuten platt gemacht in im Norden von Nigeria. Das sind alles so diese Rahmenbedingungen, dieses äh,
angeblich dem Islam zugewandten,
Terrorkommandos, die einfach nur frei drehen. So und ja, in Frankreich gibt's halt diesen Konflikt,
auch ist ja auch eins der Länder, die einfach ein deutlich höheren Bevölkerungsanteil haben, also es ne, der der Bezug von Frankreich zur islamischen Welt ist deutlich stärker als der von,
von Deutschland,
einfach schon durch die Kolonialhysterie von äh Frankreich auch mitbegründet. Ja, die Konflikte werden dort offensichtlich auch sehr viel härter ausgetragen und mit diesem Anschlag äh hat das so einen neuen,
Höhepunkt erreicht.
Ja. Und es ist halt also es hat äh.
Okay, jetzt, ich meine, das sind halt Fanatiker, ne. Du hast ja dann auch immer immer sehr schön äh die Forderung. Es müssen sich ja dann äh die islamischen.
Ähm Religionsoberhäubtal und Gemeinden oder was äh von denen wird ja dann immer eine Distanzierung verlangt, ne.
Ja, die findet auch statt.
Selbstverständlich findet die statt, aber ähm
Ich da stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, als der Brei liegt da irgendwie rumgerannt ist, ne? Da hat aber keiner von den Christen eine Distanzierung äh von diesem Nazi da verlangt, ne. Also das ist schon,
auch wirklich bitter ähm für, also es sieht einfach.
Bin da wirklich auch sprachlos und auch wirklich voller Angst, weil man da halt erkennt, dass sich da eine ähm.
Halt Fronten ergeben oder oder Positionen ergeben, die halt die du so schnell nicht wieder gekittet bekommst, ne? Und ich bin da jetzt sehr, sehr blicke mit großer Sorge auf den nächsten Montag, wenn da wieder die Idas äh aufmarschieren.
Wie viele.
Wie viel die dieser äh Sache abgewinnen können, ne? Also die äh AfD spricht's ja jetzt auch offen an, ähm selbst irgendwie, wie heißt diese äh verrückte ähm von der CDU. Erika Steinbach,
ne? Die die machen, also die die sprechen halt jetzt irgendwie konkret an und sagen, seht ihr, haben wir doch
äh ne, Islam und so, da müssen wir jetzt endlich mal einen Riegel vorschieben. Und ähm.
Die werden sicherlich dadurch äh Zulauf erhalten und daraus Kapital schlagen können und geben sich auch alle alle Mühe dazu, da mehr ähm.
Mehr Öl ins Feuer zu gießen und das erfüllt mich mit großer Sorge.
Ja, also nicht wirklich überraschend, das ist auch so ein bisschen,
täglich Gruß aus Murmeltier, das kennen wir schon, Terroranschlag, entsprechende Reaktionen. Ich meine, das das da jetzt äh also sehr viel mehr Sorgen würde ich mir eigentlich um die Situation des Frauen-National in Frankreich machen, weil da wird,
da wird es sozusagen jetzt richtig kritisch, zumal ja eben der jetzt schon so in in Wählersphären von dreißig Prozent Zuspruch und so weiter ohnehin schon steht.
Ähm für Frankreich könnte das wirklich ein großes Problem werden. Damit natürlich auch letztlich für Europa, wie wir schon bei der letzten Europawahl ja auch gemerkt haben,
Ja, das können wir jetzt derzeit nur befürchten und erahnen, wir werden's sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Genau, die die netzpolitische Relevanz zeigte sich dann auch. Also wir haben ähm.
So in dem aktivistischen Umfeld dann natürlich auch so gedacht, so okay, sind wir jetzt mal gespannt, wie lange ähm,
denn so die Sicherheitspolitiker von auf die wo, nachdem man bei sowas dann die Uhr stellen kann, wie lange die.
Anstandsperiode zumindest noch ist, ne? Und an der Anstandsperiode erkennst du ja auch vielleicht so ein bisschen ähm wie tief der äh,
Konflikt vielleicht auch schon ist, ne? Und die Anstandsperiode hat dieses Mal, glaube ich, weniger als vierundzwanzig Stunden betragen
bis dann die äh CDU CSU hervortrat und sagt, ja, seht ihr? Und deshalb brauchen wir Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Axel Voss von der CDU und ein paar andere
Europa konservative Europaparlamentarier haben auch gesagt, ja hier brauchen neue Vorratsdatenspeicherungen.
Und äh dann die EU Kommission äh drückt natürlich auf ihre komischen äh PNR-Abkommen, ne, also die Passengercke ähm,
und der äh Juncker ähm,
irgendwie eine EU-Kommission Initiative für neue Antiterrorgesetze im Februar angekündigt. Und natürlich,
Bosbach äh schießt dann weder den Vogel ab, das ist ja der Innenexperte der Union, das ist also dieser dieser
alte Mann mit den mit den mit den schwarzen Augen, ähm der dann irgendwie sagt, ein wichtiges Ziel wäre schon, wenn wir endlich einmal damit aufhören würden, neue Maßnahmen zur Sicherheit, zu Gefahrenabwehr
ständig zu kritisieren als islamophob als übertriebene Maßnahme. Ja, also der äh.
Will halt natürlich auch sofort daraus Kapital schlagen für seine ähm politischen Zielsetzungen, ne?
Ja
Und ähm jetzt habe ich das gerade aus irgendwelchen Gründen versäumt, diesen Link ins äh in das Pad hier zu werfen. Aber ähm es gab dann noch einen Artikel, in dem ein ähm.
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter der USA ähm indirekt snowden äh die Schuld daran gibt, weil ja.
Das gibt aber einen Sonderpreis für besondere Kreativität.
Weil ja, ähm Edward Snowden,
Die Geheimdienste faktisch blind gemacht hat, ja? Und äh ja, ja, das ist kein Witz,
jetzt muss ich den äh jetzt muss ich den Link natürlich noch raussuchen und habe das versäumt. Also das ist die, das ist das Niveau, was ähm innerhalb ähm.
Von weniger als vierundzwanzig Stunden in in dieser Debatte erreicht wurde.
Ja, nicht wirklich überraschend, aber trotzdem mal wieder erschreckend. Aber ich meine, so ist nun mal das politische Spiel. Irgendwas passiert und ähm ich weiß auch nicht, es gibt da irgendwie auch so einen merkwürdigen Reflex.
Bei den Politikern, dass sie der Meinung sind, sie müssten da auch,
sofort irgendwie reagieren Bezug zu nehmen,
irgendwelche Dinge fordern. Ja, das ist ja immer so dieses, irgendwas muss verschärft werden oder irgendwas, muss jetzt mal endlich mal gemacht werden. Ähm weil man muss ja so diese Illusion äh aufrechterhalten, dass man halt immer irgendwie wehrhaft,
einer tollen Idee am Start ist und dann sind halt die anderen doof, wenn's nicht gemacht wird. Hauptsache, man war selber nicht schuld.
Na ja, die Politik, also bei aller Vorsicht, ne, also man es gibt ähm.
Also es gibt natürlich einerseits diese äh äh die äh diese geschmacklosen
Typen, die halt wirklich, also so jemand wie der Bosbach, der hat halt äh längst äh jede jede Anstand irgendwie über Bord geworfen, ne? Der ist äh eiskalt und die die
appellieren und spielen ja auch mit der, mit der Angst der Menschen äh für ihre eigenen politischen Ziele. So, es gibt aber natürlich auch ähm.
An an andere also an Verantwortliche. Ähm in solchen Situationen
natürlich irgendwie einen Druck, dass sie irgendwie eine Reaktion zeigen müssen, um zu zeigen, dass sie in der Lage sind, darauf zu reagieren. Zum Beispiel äh Innenminister, Innenminister de Maizire musste natürlich jetzt auch irgendwas sagen
also hat er gesagt ja wir müssen Terrorpropaganda auf YouTube löschen also diese,
diese diese Videos, in denen dann irgendwie gesagt wird, hier heiliger Krieg oder so, ne? Also irgendwas
musst du ja äh zeigen, weil du bist ja schließlich die Regierung und du kannst ja nicht irgendwie wenn
wenn ein ein Anschlag auf die Werte der Gesellschaft stattfindet hingehen und sagen oh fuck ja da können wir leider nichts machen.
Das waren irre gegen die können wir uns gar nicht schützen.
Den Mut ihn entschieden entgegen zu treten zeigen und uns davon nicht einschüchtern lassen,
So, aber das ist natürlich irgendwie keine äh Reaktion, für die du wiedergewählt wirst, ne? Wenn du sagst, okay, hier äh ähm die kriegen jetzt alle einen Stempel in einen Ausweis und ähm,
werden an Ein- und Ausreisen gehindert und YouTube-Videos gelöscht oder so ähm,
Da erwächst ja den Eindruck, irgendwie Maßnahmen äh zu ergreifen, die irgendwas damit zu tun hätten oder vielleicht zumindest denen das Potenzial innewohnt, äh sowas in Zukunft zu verhindern. Was natürlich totaler Unsinn ist.
Dass du so etwas verhindern könntest. Aber du musst halt irgendwas, du bist ja irgend 'ne Reaktion zeigen.
Genau, irgendeine Reaktion muss man zeigen, weil sonst ist man ja irgendwie fehl am Platz.
Ja, ist nicht wiedergewählt und du bist ja schließlich da um um die Menschen zu schützen.
Genau, ne? Ist auf jeden Fall nicht überraschend, dass jetzt wieder der Klassiker vor Ortsdatenspeicherung äh ausgegraben wird. Das kommt ja dann immer als erstes so. Oder? Also.
Ja ja, Vorratsdatensprechung ist immer ganz wichtig, damit hätten wir alles verhindern können
interessanterweise also ist ja auch alles so wiedergekaut, ne? Wirst du ja auch als als Aktivist in diesem Bereich ähm ich glaube, Markus äh hat das dann auch gemacht. Der hat ja dann einfach äh irgendwann äh also als dieser
ähm als dieser kurz nach diesem
äh Attentat oder nach diesem Angriff ähm in Paris hat er dann einfach nur einen Artikel von, weiß ich nicht, zweitausendacht oder zweitausendsechs oder so was äh wiedergeholt und hat den einfach nochmal, hat den nochmal verlinkt. Er hat gesagt
das, was wir damals schrieben, ist jetzt natürlich geschrieben haben, ist jetzt wieder äh relevant geworden, ne. Und ähm.
Bei welchen welches Attentat ging's da?
Das äh ich muss leider sagen, dass ich dem dem Link dann nicht gefolgt bin, sondern ich schaue jetzt gleich ganz kurz.
Das war wahrscheinlich na, zweitausendsechs war jetzt nicht breit weg, oder? Nee.
Nee, ich weiß, ich habe jetzt auch einfach irgendwie ein Jahr äh.
Ja auch egal, du hast dir einfach irgendwas einfallen lassen, das ist gut, so macht das.
Leider wieder aktuell die Bilder der Anschläge im Kopf Widerspruch zwischen Angst vor Terrorismus und Wirklichkeit und der Artikel war von zweitausendzehn auch nicht von.
Von Markus, sondern von Florian Alt hergeschrieben.
Und da ging's auch wieder so Innenministerkonferenz, Terroranschläge, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ähm da sagte dann wer sich jetzt noch gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wehrt, hat die Bedrohungslage nicht verstanden,
und so weiter.
Yada, Yalla.
Der schöne Teile, die die äh.
Der eigentlich offenkundige Widerspruch ist ja, dass die Vorratsdatensprechung.
Immer nur zur äh Aufklärung von Straftaten motiviert war oder in den in den Gesetzen, die ich so gesehen habe, aber beworben wurde als Mittel zur Verhinderung von Straftaten, ne?
Was ja dann auch der logische nächste Schritt ist, wenn du die Daten hast, äh dass du dann als nächstes sagst, hey ja, das kann ja nicht sein, äh dass wir diese Daten haben, aber nicht nutzen, um vorher halt reinzuschauen. Und ähm.
Na ja,
in dem Zusammenhang sei darauf hingewiesen, dass es seit zweitausendvier eine Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatte in Frankreich gab. Dort wurde die
eine Form der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zweitausendsechs zum ersten Mal ähm eingeführt und zwar inklusive
einem Gesetz zur Videoüberwachung und zur Fluggastdatenspeicherung, also genau dieses PNR-Zeug. Ähm,
zweitausendelf wurde dann äh
durch die Umsetzung der EU-Richtlinien quasi nochmals für eine äh also für eine modifizierte äh Speicherung äh gesorgt. Und im letzten Jahr haben sie dann dort einen ähm Antiterrorgesetz.
Verabschiedet. Also alle Maßnahmen, äh die uns jetzt,
Die unsere Feinde der Freiheit, die ja Hand in Hand arbeiten mit äh den anderen Feinden der Freiheit und sich da äh wunderbar ergänzen. Ähm.
Die haben es nicht geschafft, äh dass in Frankreich zu verhindern, die werden's auch äh woanders nicht äh schaffen, irgendwas zu verhindern, ne? Und das ähm wir haben ja sogar über die NSA-Überwachung das
die USA mit dem in Erklärungsnot, dass sie nicht einen einzigen Anschlag benennen können, den sie mithilfe dieses dieses ganzen Aufrisses
hätten verhindern können und in selbst in Deutschland wird immer auf irgendwie so ein paar Typen gezeigt, die irgendwie was weiß ich da am am.
Eine nicht funktionierende Bombe an irgendein Bahnhof äh haben liegen lassen, ne? Also ähm es ist äh.
Arsträubend.
Es ist halt haarsträubend diese Maßnahmen sind halt nicht in der Lage, äh solche einen Schutz vor solchen Angriffen zu bieten.
Man muss auch trotzdem ähm.
Also man muss da halt sehr, sehr besonnen auch drauf klicken, ne. Ich meine, ein Angriff auf die auf die Meinungs- und Pressefreiheit in in so brutaler Form, ja, äh ist.
Ist ja auch wirklich, wirklich schwer ähm irgendwie zu aufzunehmen und zu verkraften und da, wie gesagt, mir wird da auch schlecht, wenn ich darüber nachdenke. Und natürlich stellt einen das vorne ähm.
Vor einem wie soll man das sagen, emotionale Herausforderung, äh bei sowas trotzdem ähm,
besonnen zu reagieren,
und ähm dieser Herausforderungen sind äh viele Menschen eben leider auch nicht gewachsen. Und ähm,
schüren da jetzt auf die ein oder die andere Weise äh Gift für die Gesellschaft, ob sie jetzt äh sagen, irgendwie den
eine gesamte äh Religionsgemeinschaft da jetzt äh für verantwortlich machen oder ob sie
Irgendwie welche unsinnigen Gesetze fordern, die unser aller äh Zusammenleben in der Freiheit einschränken würden. Ne, also das ist äh.
Schwierig und für viele Menschen offenbar äh sind viele Menschen sind offenbar nicht in der Lage, auch dieser dieser Versuchung ähm.
Zu widerstehen für komplexe gesellschaftliche Phänomene, sehr einfache ähm Lösungen formulieren zu wollen.
Ja, das, ja, das ist natürlich das das Grunddilemma der menschlichen Gesellschaften, würde ich sagen, ja,
es ist jetzt irgendwie auch gar nichts spezifisches und ähm zeigt sich ja immer wieder, in dem Moment, wo man einfach äh auch die Ruhe bewahrt, ja, und und sich äh da auch eine offene Gesellschaft weiterhin äh leistet, dann,
kann es sich halt genauso normalisieren. Ich meine, was jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang immer gerne ähm zitiert wird, ist natürlich die Reaktion von,
Norwegen.
Doltenberg oder wie hieß er? Ja.
Herr Stoltenberg, der ja mittlerweile NATO-Generalsekretär ist, ne. Ähm,
äh auf die Anschläge von äh diesem Andreas Breiwick, der halt anders, anders,
wo sie ja dann im Prinzip darauf reagiert haben. Zunächst einmal mit äh ja wir werden uns jetzt hier irgendwie unsere Freiheit nicht äh einschränken lassen und äh wir versuchen jetzt bewusst noch eine offenere Gesellschaft zu sein. Inwiefern das jetzt auch wirklich nur.
Also inwiefern das jetzt nur ein Spruch war, ja und das äh wie sich das in Norwegen tatsächlich entwickelt hat, bin ich gar nicht kompetent, ähm mich dazu zu äußern.
Aber äh ich denke, dass dass das schon einfach die richtige Reaktion ist, weil am Ende muss man ja auch feststellen.
Sone Leute und solche militärisch geplanten Aktionen, die kann man nicht verhindern. Also,
das ist einfach das einzige, was man machen kann, ist die Gesamtsituation zu verbessern. Derzeit haben wir es halt einfach mit mit so mega Krisenherden zu tun. Sicherlich
ähm spielt die islamische Welt da jetzt eine besondere Rolle. Ja, aber ist da keineswegs
die einzige anfällige, ich meine wir haben ja ähnliche Terroranschläge eben wie mit aber auch in den USA und so weiter, aus rechten Kreisen. Also aus allen möglichen verstörten,
Gruppen heraus immer wieder gehabt,
unterm Strich ist halt die eigentliche Wirkung von Terror, nämlich genau das, was der Name eben sagt. Das ist einfach diese Schockwirkung, die auf die Gesellschaft gehen soll, die sie dazu zwingen soll, bestimmte Reaktionen zu zeigen.
Von den Zahlen her ist ja nun Terror nicht wirklich ein Problem, nicht so, dass es irgendwie am laufenden Meter stattfindet. Ähm sonst sind halt immer nur vereinzelte Schläge
die eben versuchen, durch eine besondere Brutalität und eine besondere äh Plakativität äh eine Gesellschaft,
falsche Richtung zurück.
Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt, ob wir wollen oder nicht, äh Witze über den Propheten machen.
Genau.
Ja, es war so, also meine Geschehe hat's nicht anders gewollt. So, ich meine, äh.
Mir fällt jetzt allerdings gerade keiner ein.
Mir auch nicht, aber es gibt äh sehr viele Cartoons gerade, die das auch tun. Das finde ich auch eine sehr, also ist natürlich auch ähm.
Nee, also es ist ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das ähm ist das jetzt so gut, dass die also ich sehe das zum Beispiel mit gespaltenen Gefühlen, ähm dass jetzt natürlich also.
Ähm jetzt eine Welle von äh Karikaturen und Cartoons.
Kommt, die eben ja den äh diese Religion verhöhnen, ne.
Glücklicherweise auch viele, die dann äh direkt Jesus äh äh mitverarschen. Ähm.
Und natürlich ist das so, die ist das eine der irgendwie auch notwendigen Reaktionen zu zeigen, pass mal auf, wir haben noch viel mehr Witze
Ähm andererseits äh führt das natürlich auch so diese beleidigt das halt wirklich Menschen, ne? Also ähm.
Ich persönlich bin jetzt ein ähm
großer Feind von Religion, halt das für für absoluten Unsinn, ne? Und das ist auch, das muss auch eine Gesellschaft äh auf jeden Fall abkönnen, dass man sich über Religionen lustig macht und auch über den Papst und äh haste nicht gesehen
Ähm das ist, dass es sicherlich wichtig. Ähm andererseits ist das natürlich äh,
führt das natürlich in so einer Situation jetzt nicht unbedingt zu einer Befriedung der Gesamtgesellschaft, ne, wenn ähm wenn man jetzt,
quasi als ähm äh Gläubiger ähm damit auseinander damit konfront
wird, dass Menschen, die man selber verurteilt, Morde begangen haben und dass man jetzt noch dazu äh die ganz überall irgendwie so
so Cartoons sehen muss, in denen halt gegen die eigenen religiösen Gefühle
geschossen wird. Also es ist halt schwierig so, es ist halt keine es ist notwendig, da müssen wir jetzt durch und da müssen auch die Islamgläubigen jetzt leider durch mit uns gemeinsam.
Ja
Aber ähm,
es birgt natürlich auch das Risiko, dass deren Gefühle halt da in einem Maß verletzt werden und in denen halt eine innere Spannung aufgebaut wird, die jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zu zu einer Verständigung zufrieden beiträgt.
Ja, nee, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt besonders klug sein. Ich meine, Gott sei Dank, die meisten Karikaturen, die ich gesehen habe, haben die Situation als solche aufgegriffen, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt versucht, jetzt nochmal jetzt hauen wir nochmal extra auf die Kacke, ja.
Bin gespannt, nächste Woche Charlie Abdu, äh will ja trotzdem mit anderen neuen Ausgabe erscheinen pünktlich am Montag.
Wie das normalerweise auch gewesen wäre, nur eben nicht in der normalen Auflage mehr, der sich erscheinen von, glaube ich, so sechzig, achtzigtausend, sondern irgendwie so in der Größenordnung von einer Million gedruckten Exzellenplan,
Das wird sicherlich sehr interessant sein zu sehen, wie die da selber reagieren. Ich persönlich fand ja die Titanic-Reaktion irgendwie am souveränsten.
Ja das Sonneborn hat das gesagt, oder? Das äh.
Sonnenborn hat auch noch irgendwas gesagt. Das erinnere ich jetzt gerade nicht, wenn du das äh Zitat am Start hast. Weiß nicht, aber es gab so diese typischen Kurzmeldungen von von Titanic, die sie ja dann immer so mit äh twittern
wo sie darauf hinwiesen, dass ja dann
nächste Woche äh ein Redaktionstreffen bei ihnen wäre und es werden aber auch noch äh Vertreter der gesamten Lügenpresse auch noch anwesend vom Hessischen Rundfunk und so weiter und und das wäre doch eine ideale Gelegenheit für Terroristen, da ich richtig abzuräumen.
So schmerzfrei. Ja.
Also äh Sonneborn äh schrieb auf Facebook. Äh das ist nicht komisch, mit Anzeigen Abo-Kündigungen oder Kalaschnikow geballert auf Satire zu reagieren, gilt in der Szene als Unfein.
Ja, da habt ihr recht, ja.
Das ist schlimm.
Äh
Kündigung und Kalaschtikowk geballert.
Ja, also das ist ein gutes Beispiel für ähm den Kopf erhoben, denn erhobtes Weitertragen. Äh ich meine, ich bin mir sicher, dass sie dabei
der Zitat Redaktion, wie bestimmt bei allen anderen, befreundeten Satiremagazinen da schon auch ihren Schock weg äh haben, ne.
Ja, wobei äh Sonneborn ist ja äh beruhigt und sagt, bei Titanic könnte so etwas nicht passieren.
Hätten ja nur sechs Mitarbeiter.
Sechs Redakteure.
Ja, das meine ich. Das ist einfach, einfach äh souverän, ne.
Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
Genau. Ja. Also, wir fassen zusammen
Frankreich hatte eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das volle Programm vielleicht nicht, aber zumindest äh all das, was sich äh ein Herr Bosbach und ein Herr Uhl schon immer äh herbei fantasieren und zusammenträumen und
das hilft halt gegen solche Sachen überhaupt nicht. Ähm.
Das wird sich überhaupt auch zeigen, äh wie wehrhaft denn jetzt da die äh französische Polizei ist in dem Fall. Äh SW,
läuft da irgendwie grade auch ein Einsatz so, keine Ahnung, wie das ausgeht, wann wie lange sich das noch
Hinzieht, aber derzeit ist da halt einfach grade,
alles durcheinander und es wird irgendwie gefahndet. Wir wissen noch nicht, wie's ausgeht.
Ich würde noch kurz ergänzen, dass du sagst, alles was die sich äh herbeifantasieren, ne? Da ist natürlich noch wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, würde jetzt ähm eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt und irgendwie Antiterrorgesetze und,
Menschen nach Regionen sortiert und äh Stempel in Ausweise und ähm haste nicht gesehen, was alles passieren. Dann ist das ja nicht so, als würden,
Bosbach und Uhl sich dann in den Schaukelstuhl setzen und auf ihr getanes Lebenswerk blicken. Nein, dann würden sie ja weitermachen. Also es ist
das sind ja nicht Leute, die ähm
Ein erklärtes Ziel haben, dass sie erreichen könnten. So, das sind halt ähm Extremisten und die würden halt weitermachen. So, da dann sagst du sechs Monate vorzeitenspeicherung, dann würden die als nächstes rumschreien, dass wir zwölf brauchen, ja?
Und dann würden sie halt sagen, dass wenn Vorratsdatenspeicherung für was nicht alles brauchen. Also die ähm
Es ist nicht so, als hätten die einen einen erklärten Endzustand, auf den sie hinarbeiten, der irgendwie in reichbarer Nähe ist, um durch den man durch dessen Erreiche man diese Vögel einfach alle mal loswerden könnte.
Ne, so sieht's aus.
Jut, aber das Thema durch. Ja, ne. Genau. Ja, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Sonst haben wir eigentlich nicht so viel. Jetzt können wir eigentlich nochmal auf unseren schönen Kongress zurückblicken.
Ja, müssen wir wohl.
Müssen wir auf Mangelung anderer Themen.
Also ich ich würde gerne eine, ich fand eine Sache sehr spannend bei diesem Kongress und das ist ähm.
Ähm das ist der,
ich schaue natürlich auch immer so auf das auf die ähm auf das Echo bei diesem Kongress und ähm
die die Besucher ne also wie sie Besucher und Besucherinnen den Kongress wahrgenommen haben
Und ähm dieses Mal waren's ja nochmal knapp äh zweitausend Besucher mehr als im letzten Jahr. Und jetzt ist natürlich die ähm war natürlich die Frage, wer sind diese zweitausend Leute mehr?
Ne, sind das äh sind das jetzt alles irgendwie ähm,
Hacker oder wer kommt da mehr zu diesem Kongress hin, ne? Sind das ähm politisch Interessierte, sind das technisch interessierte? Und natürlich war es eine eine große Mischung.
Aber das, was ich wahrnehme war in in diesem Jahr fand, ähm sind ähm,
Blogartikel und begeisterte Berichte von.
Ja äh also Eltern eigentlich. Das war das, was ich am, also ähm Mütter.
Die mit ihren Kindern da waren. Das waren also die Berichte, die mich am meisten
auch auf 'ne Weise gefreut haben und gesagt haben ich war mit den Kindern da, die Kinder haben, konnten überall spielen, das war höchst interessant für mich, hab da vier Tage Spannung, Familienausflug zum einunddreißig C drei, kommt alle, bringt eure Kinder mit und so, ne?
Das das fand ich eigentlich am am interessantesten, weil dieser, das ist dann Kids Base gibt und dass das ein super geiler Kongress ist für Kinder, das ist ja nicht erst dieses Jahr so.
War ja schon immer so, dass es den oder nicht schon immer, aber.
Nee, immer nicht, nee.
Gibt seit Jahren den jungen Hackertag, ne? Und ähm,
dass es ist natürlich auf jeden Fall für für Kinder interessant da und diese diese Kidsbase und so, das ist ja jetzt alles, das gab's ja schon, gibt's ja alles schon länger und ähm,
hat sich glaube ich irgendwie daraus ergeben, dass äh die,
dass die Community selber halt irgendwann auch kleine Junghacker gebaut hat und äh die ja auch irgendwie da beschäftigt werden mussten, während die Eltern äh,
sich irgendwie mit den mit ihrer äh mit ihren Interessen auseinandersetzen.
Ähm aber die jetzt so war für mich gefühlt zum ersten Mal das so Familienveranstaltungen einunddreißig C drei. Und das finde ich natürlich eine sehr äh eine sehr positive Entwicklung.
Ähm dass diese Öffnung ähm der Veranstaltung in die,
Breite der Gesellschaft jetzt da so wirklich auch richtig spürbar ist. Gleichzeitig gibt's aber natürlich ähm.
Personen, die dann da auch sagen, das ist eine Entwicklung, die sie äh, der sie kritisch gegenüberstehen, weil das ja ähm,
Kongress ist, ne? Und äh man da eben auf äh auf seine ähm.
Leute und seine Community hofft und auf technische Themen und man möchte eben nicht, dass dass da Menschen hinkommen, die sich dann nachher beklagen, dass der Vortrag zu technisch war und sie das nicht verstanden haben. Man möchte da halt unter sich sein, ne. Also so ein bisschen dieser äh ich nenne das immer den, den, den schwulen Bar-Effekt.
Ja, die, die, du, du, du, äh, das ist damit spiele ich auf das ähm.
Auf das Buch äh Herr Lehmann an. Ähm,
wo die wo die Heteros in eine Schulenbar gehen und dann sagen die sagen die sagt, sagen die Schwulen halt so, ey ähm wir wollen euch hier nicht, ne? Wir haben wir haben hier, geht in eure Hetero Bars, ne,
Wir haben ja bei einem Schulenbau gebaut. So und ähm dann dann streiten sie sich halt darüber, ähm ob das jetzt in Ordnung ist oder nicht, ne? Und ähm.
Das äh ist natürlich schon auch interessant. Ich meine, du machst natürlich eine du machst eine eine homosexuelle Institution, weil du möchtest, dass dass halt dieser Diephold eben
Homosexualität ist, weil ihr als Homosexuelle Person in irgendeiner Kneipe immer das Problem hast, dass du nicht weißt, äh ne, ob du dir jetzt vielleicht
ein Problem einhandelst, wenn du das Objekt der Begierde äh anmachst. Und äh so äh,
ähm auf jeden Fall sind dieser dieser Effekt sind halt gesellschaftlich ausgegrenzt und müssen sich,
mussten sich dann eben für sich ihre Räume schaffen und ähm das ist ja auch äh wichtig, dass das geschehen ist und hat halt rettet glaube ich ähm.
Für viele Menschen so, die die äh die geistige Gesundheit, dass man eben unter Gleichgesinnten sein kann, ähm,
Egal, wie weit man von von dem entfernt ist, was irgendwie als Normalität äh betrachtet wird. Und das ist natürlich bei der, bei der Hacker-Community auch so.
So und diese Sorge kann ich also ähm nachvollziehen und deswegen freue mich auch dieser Artikel so
für mich der Kongress überhaupt nicht anders war als viele Jahre davor gut waren mehr Menschen, ja? Aber ich habe denen überhaupt nicht anders wahrgenommen
Und da ist mir ist mir irgendwie zum ersten Mal klar geworden, dass der Kongress in dieser Größe ähm.
Mit diesem vielfältigen Angebot inzwischen eine Veranstaltung ist, wo du im Prinzip,
als jemand, der sich für IT-Security interessiert, hingehen kannst, ungefähr dreißig, vierzig Vorträge zu dem Thema hast, ähm die weltbesten äh Security Forscher dort hast und,
einfach vier Tage reines ähm.
Hardcore IT Security geben kannst, als politisch interessierte Aktivist ähm
internationale Leute da hast, irgendwie aus Frankreich, Amerika und allen Ländern dieser Erde und dich nur mit netzpolitischem Aktivismus auseinandersetzen kannst.
Und ähm oder du gehst als Podcasthörer dahin und kannst dich irgendwie vier Tage nur mit dem Sendezentrum auseinandersetzen.
Und du kannst eben auch als als Familie da hingehen und dich vier Tage damit auseinandersetzen, dass dein Kind äh Schlösser knackt, ähm was lötet ähm.
Geschmiedet. Ringe schmiedet.
Oder okay, also das fand ich äh die war an zum Glück so weit weg von unserem, dass.
War ganz schön laut, ja.
Boah. Ne, aber äh genau, kannst du, wenn's sein muss, kannst du auch noch einen Ring schmieden von mir aus, ne. Und das quasi, du kannst den Kongress auf so viele Weisen wahrnehmen.
Ähm,
Das ist quasi gar nicht den Kongress gibt, sondern deinen Kongress. Und das äh ist das war irgendwie was, was ich äh wirklich auch dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal wirklich gecheckt habe.
Ja die Vielfalt ist schon enorm und das hat natürlich über die Jahre wirklich äh extrem zugenommen,
und es hat sie auch so perfektioniert, also grad so diese Kindersituation, das ist noch nicht so lange her, dass das wirklich äh so gut geworden ist, dass.
Das gab's in Berlin auch schon immer im.
Nicht wirklich nein, also.
Ja, es gab eine Lego-Ecke, aber das war's dann auch, aber es war, sagen wir mal, insgesamt nicht jetzt unbedingt so eine Atmosphäre, wo du jetzt äh deine Kinder einfach frei hättest laufen lassen, so. Also ich habe halt auch irgendwie von vielen gehört, so ja, äh
kommst du da mit deinem Kind und dann dann ist das halt irgendwie weg. So, ja und das ist dann zwar erstmal in so einer
ituation, wo du denkst, so, ah okay, sind ja sind ja nur zehntausend andere Leute hier so, ja, da könnte man sich halt schon mal Gedanken machen, aber da ist es dann halt doch nicht so das Problem,
also hängt natürlich immer ganz davon ab, wie protektiv äh jeweilige Elternteil so drauf ist. Aber es ist einfach so eine Atmosphäre, wo sich die Kids auch einfach extrem wohlfühlen und an vielen Stellen haben problemlos andocken können. Das war jetzt in Berlin so noch nicht so der Fall.
Ja, okay, also.
Wie auch immer, also das was du ja sagen willst, es verbessert sich, es stellt sich breiter auf und der Kongress ist halt also,
Ich mache halt auch immer so den Witz irgendwie, den werde ich dir gegen dir gegenüber auch mal gerissen haben, wenn man dann so unten dieser Partytanzfläche steht und der wilde Mob irgendwie äh danst da vor sich hin so, dass sie einfach nur draufzeige und sage hier guck mal.
Gar keinen Kongress. Total Stereotyp so, ja.
Ich glaube, wer wer mit so einem Stereotypenbild ähm dahin geht, der der wird die Welt nicht mehr verstehen. Also das ist einfach sehr weit davon entfernt.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Ähm.
Also insgesamt glaube ich, das ist jetzt, es hat sich wahrscheinlich gewandelt von äh dem Kongress der Hacker für die Hacker, zu dem Kongress der Hacker für,
sich und alle. Ja, also ähm.
Und jetzt gibt's natürlich dann auch die Sorge, dass äh jetzt neben uns äh jetzt platzen die Kapazitäten und bald werden wieder bald kriegt man dann kein Ticket mehr oder so. Ich meine, da das ist, glaube ich, noch eine äh das,
steht noch in den Sternen, ob das wirklich so passieren wird. Also da müsste man nochmal ähm wirklich sehr, sehr viel mehr Menschen anziehen. Ähm aber.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre der Kongress die einzige Veranstaltung des Cross Computerclubs.
Nö. Also das.
Ganz im Gegenteil, ne? Also die die Veranstaltung äh die Hacker zentrierten Veranstaltungen ähm,
Die gibt's ja auch über das Jahr verteilt, ne, wo man dann irgendwie seinen in der Community schön mit Stahlgeruch und so äh,
schmieden kann, ne? Das äh so ist das ja nicht. Und das wäre auch schade, wenn's das nicht gäbe, ne.
Ja, ja. Genau. Ja, mittlerweile gibt's so viele Kleinstableger, äh die so locker die Größe eines ehemaligen Kongresses erreichen, ja? Da kann man, glaube ich, schon so vier oder fünf aufzählen, die so und so in die Richtung gehen.
Ja, also ich fand das auch alles sehr befriedigend und ähm diese ganzen Bobbeiträge da draußen, die so davon berichten, wie schön es auch auf dem Kongress war und wie überraschend das war. Ja, das finde ich auch sehr,
Also es freut mich,
Freut mich einfach extrem, dass das auch so gesehen wird, weil ich denke, so eine gewisse Innenwahrnehmung hatten wir schon, ne, weil dieses Abschotten war eigentlich nie so das Programm, seitdem der Kongress in,
Berlin ist, gab's eigentlich schon immer den Wunsch sich breiter aufzustellen,
nicht mal jetzt so im Hinblick auf na ja, dass jetzt sozusagen auch Elternteile und, und, und, und, und der Normalbürger sich hier auch äh wunderbar findet, sondern dass man vor allem auch äh so eine kulturelle Breitenaufstellung erreicht, weil.
Für mich ist ja die Hacker-Szene nicht unbedingt so definiert durch den Computer,
Sie ist für mich äh definiert durch Menschen, die einfach das Kritische Denken schätzen,
und die einfach eine gewisse Grundeinstellung, gewisse skeptische Grundeinstellung gegenüber Medien und, und, und, und, und wie die Welt sich so äh gerne sieht,
ne
man stellt's halt in Frage. Man man hinterfragt, man schaut genau nach und das sind ja eigentlich auch immer diese Inhalte, dass sich das bei Computern eben so wunderbar ausspielen lässt, ist klar, aber im Prinzip geht es ja eben genauso auf alle gesellschaftspolitischen Bereiche auch,
mit und von daher habe ich mir schon immer auch gewünscht, dass der Kongress jetzt sozusagen als als wichtigste Veranstaltung des Clubs.
Es auch schafft, eben explizit andere Gesellschaftsbereiche stärker mit einzubeziehen, dass wir eben Vorträge bekommen von ganz anderen,
Leuten, die irgendwie eine eine in ihrer Szene eine ähnliche Sicht haben und ähnliche äh Betrachtungen haben, weil es einfach so auf aus einer anderen Perspektive heraus schildert. Da finde ich es im Kongressprogramm auch noch eine Menge zu tun
das ist schon noch sehr ähm computerlastig mit Ausnahmen.
Ähm aber es zeigt sich eben zum Beispiel mit dieser mittlerweile ja schon fast perfekt funktionierende Verbindung mit der Partyszene, also was da einfach so,
Feierkulturell abläuft, ja? Ich sag jetzt,
Für mich ist das halt mehr als jetzt nur, ah ja, da ist ja jetzt noch Musik und man kann noch ein Bierchen trinken, sondern das ist eben auch schon ein ein andocken, auch kritischer Geister. Ich meine, wenn man äh die Partyszene ein bisschen kennt, ich meine,
Das das ist auch voll mit Leuten, die ähm der Welt kritisch gegenüberstehen.
Ja, kritisch, aber mit einer positiven Utopie, ne? Also das ist eigentlich das, was ich äh was ähm was das auch für mich ausmacht, ne? Oder was auch diese Veranstaltung so besonders macht. Ähm.
Da sind Leute, die haben einerseits äh schon den den Ernst der Laarge verstanden. So, aber äh auch nicht aufgegeben ähm auf eine auf eine,
positive, offene äh
Welt äh hinzuarbeiten und ihren Beitrag dazu zu leisten, ne? Das ist eigentlich das, was diesen was was diese Veranstaltung ausmacht. Und ähm
Ja, das ist schön, dass das, dass sich das, dass sich das öffnet. Ähm irgendwann werden wir's wahrscheinlich dann werden wir halt überrannt, da müssen wir halt zumachen. Und äh wieder klein anfangen. Wer weiß, ähm
Aber wenn man eben mit dieser positiven Utopie und an das Gute im Menschen glauben,
weitermachen möchte, dann äh ist das natürlich auch immer schön, wenn wenn man in andere Bereiche der Gesellschaft ähm,
seine Wirkung entfalten kann.
Ja, so ist das. Hast du denn noch ein paar Vorträge gesehen?
Ja, ich habe ja äh, wie gesagt, dann äh vom einunddreißigsten zwölften bis fünften Januar äh Bing Watching gemacht. So, das ging halt in allem durch.
Und wir haben aber ja auch schon in unserer letzten Folge so ein bisschen äh Vorträge ähm.
Beworben und gefeatured. Deswegen will ich jetzt da vielleicht gar nicht irgendwie so viel noch mal erwähnen. Ähm.
Sondern mal auf diese auf äh insbesondere einen Vortrag eingehen, der wo ich ähm ob das Verlauf Office ja äh,
überrascht war. Und zwar ist das der Vortrag von Bills Gennow, der.
Vor fünfundzwanzig Jahren auf der Abhörstation äh Berliner Teufelsberg gearbeitet hat. Ähm damals war er so irgendwie in seinen zwanzigern,
und der Wahrheit NSA-Agent, der dort eben Aufklärung äh betrieben hat,
und hat äh finde ich einen einmaligen Einblick so in diese Erlebniswelt des NSA-Agenten äh gegeben. Und ähm.
Beziehungsweise Analysten, wie er sich ja selber bezeichnet hat. Also, also er war jetzt auch kein, kein, kein Techniker, konnte auch
die Fragen äh dazu nicht so direkt beantworten, was da jetzt für Computersysteme und so weiter zum Einsatz kam, was natürlich die Posi da durchaus interessiert hätte
sondern er war halt so derjenige, bei dem eben so Informationen gelandet sind und der sie eben zu analysieren hatte, um sie dann äh auszuwerten, um zu schauen, äh was man dann nach oben weiter reicht.
Genau und er erschloss äh mit ähm,
mit einer natürlich etwas streitbaren äh Conclusio und sagte so, ja äh Teufelsberg wäre quasi das goldene Zeitalter der äh der Spionage gewesen. Ähm und äh,
plädierte also für eine Unterscheidung von ähm äh.
Gezielter Überwachung und Massenüberwachung.
Und äh das kam aber bei dem bei einigen Leuten im Publikum irgendwie überhaupt nicht gut an
die ihn dann als bezeichnet haben, ob seiner unkritischen,
Darstellung des eigenen Wirkens, die ich eigentlich so gar nicht wahrgenommen habe. Also die Publikumsreaktionen waren da glaube ich eher so ein bisschen schade, weil sie auch so eine gewisse.
Nicht unbedingt äh repräsentiert haben, wie das generell aufgenommen wurde.
Erstens das und zweitens auch so einem bisschen mangelnde Reife der der Rezipienten da gezeigt hat, weil das natürlich wirklich eine einmaliger, ein einmaliger Einblick war. Das kriegst du so nie wieder, dass dir jemand äh so offen
äh davon erzählt, wie er diese Welt eben erlebt und erfahren hat. Ja, das war äh einmalig.
Ja und ich meine, seine Position ist auch nachzuvollziehen. Ich meine, es war ja im Wesentlichen dieses so wie wir haben da äh in einem der härtesten politischen Konflikte der Geschichte. Ähm es immerhin geschafft, dass es eben nicht, dass der kalte Krieg,
kalt blieb. So, ja oder haben wir dazu beigetragen, nicht, dass er sich da jetzt als einziger ähm Grund dafür sah, aber das war schon
ähm so seine seine Kern äh Betrachtung, ne? Und das hat das natürlich alles ein bisschen anders sieht, als jemand, der nicht so ein Apparat drinsteckt. Ja, aber,
die Reaktion jetzt auch nicht besonders toll mit ja okay das erste ging noch mit ja gut darum ging's gar nicht so.
Ähm und.
Na ja, das ist.
Ja, nee, kann man, kann man sich anschauen, ist äh interessante Blick in eine interessante Zeit.
Dann ein Thema, was wir im Logbuch Netzpolitik ähm ja leider immer ähm,
seit Monaten äh bösartig und unentschuldbar äh ausgelassen haben. Das sind die Freihandelsabkommen.
TTIP.
Gibt's einen äh schönen Vortrag von Katharina Nokuhn und einer Kollegin von ihr äh zum mit dem Titel deine Rechte sind in diesen Freihandelsabkommen nicht verfügbar,
Wir müssen dann jetzt äh hoffentlich mal es schaffen, die Katharina mal ins Lock hochzuholen, um uns da in Zukunft äh auf dem auf dem Laufenden zu halten.
Der sei also auch nochmal hier äh empfohlen. Ich ich nehme jetzt mal äh gezielt die hier raus, die vielleicht nicht so äh ohnehin schon bekannt sind und äh an allen Ecken und Enden empfohlen werden.
Ähm dann,
Was ich wirklich, äh was, was wirklich auch ein krasser Vortrag ist, äh ist der von äh Erich Möchel. Ähm
Erich Möchel ist ja quasi so der Erfinder des netzpolitischen Journalismus. Ja, der hat die mit der Future Zone damals so das erste ähm ja.
Line-Magazin für netzpolitische Fokussierung.
Genau, das ist quasi so der, das ist der, der Godfaber. Und ähm ein äh ein sehr äh.
Also ein Nerd, ne? Also auf auf seine Weise der äh sein Österreicher und ähm der hat sich.
Der hat im Prinzip mal das gemacht, was man was man eigentlich viel mehr sich gewünscht hätte,
Als Reaktion auf die Snowden-Dokumente, denn der hat irgendwie gesehen, aha.
Hier ist ein Snowden-Dokument, da steht irgendwie drin, äh Kryptonym, also irgendein Name, Standort in Wien.
Und der Erich ist auch noch Amateurfunker. Kennt sich also mit Antennencharakteristiker aus und dann ist er eben mal losgegangen und hat recherchiert, wo denn wohl die NSA-Standorte in Wien sind
Und was für Antennen die aufm Dach haben und was man, was was das für
Produkte sind, in welchen Bereichen die senden oder abhören können und worauf sie gerichtet sind. Und er hat einfach mal äh durch längere Spaziergänge in Wien und ein bisschen Recherche ähm,
sehr, sehr viel über die NSA oder die NSA Standorte in Wien äh heraus gefunden und dort präsentiert. Leider ähm hat er äh größere Schwierigkeiten im Laufe des Vortrags mit ähm,
äh mit seiner Technik und mit seinen Augen, weil er kurzsichtig ist. Und ich so, nicht so ganz mit dem mit dem Computer da an der Stelle dann äh zurecht kam und ähm,
leider ist er auch äh viel zu sehr Nerd, um in dem Vortrag zu betonen, wie wie geil das eigentlich ist, was er da gemacht hat. Ja, der ist viel zu sehr interessiert an allem,
um damit anzugeben, wie krass er das alles herausrecherchiert hat.
Sodass man da sitzt und und teilweise ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten hat, ihm äh zu folgen und zu erkennen, was er da krasses.
So, ob das jetzt irgendwie schon bekanntes Wissen ist oder ob er das irgendwie recherchiert hat. Ähm,
den den Vortrag, äh dem mal in Ruhe zu folgen, dass äh das lohnt sich und da sieht man mal wirklich, was,
Ja, was eben investigativer Journalismus ist und was jemand ist, der sich mal wirklich mit einem Thema auseinandersetzt. Das äh finde ich schon sehr äh fand ich da sehr ähm.
Ja, davon abgesehen, dass der Erich auch einfach geiler Typ. Das ist einfach eine geile Sau. Den musst du einfach mal gesehen haben
Ja, also der ist auch, er ist ja auch ein ein ewiger äh Wegbegleiter des des Disclubs irgendwie, der hängt schon aufm ersten Camp ab und länger äh ist der sozusagen in unserem Umfeld, auch wenn er vielleicht nicht so den Bekanntheitsgrad
ähm genießt sein äh
Oberösterreichischer Dialekt ist auch vom Feinsten. Da kann man dann auch nochmal so ein bisschen seine Sprachkenntnisse äh aufbessern.
Ja, sollten auch mal zusehen, dass wir den Erich vielleicht auch mal äh ins Logbuch einladen, wenn er vielleicht mal in Berlin ist oder was ich so noch so anbietet.
Ja, also den den auf jeden Fall auch mal anschauen. Dann ähm.
Auch sehr interessant äh äh James Bamfort. Ähm,
Journalist und Autor zu NSA-Themen, der in dem Vortrag im Prinzip ähm also,
Er ist quasi derjenige, der publik gemacht hat
oder in der Breite publik gemacht hat, dass das die NSA gibt so ungefähr, ja? Also der setzt sich seit drei Jahrzehnten mit der NSA auseinander, hat da mehrere Bücher zu geschrieben und der hat äh den Anfang der ähm.
Sage ich mal, der feindlichen Übernahme der NSA von Kommunikationsprovidern äh da geschildert, also schon vor hundert Jahren, als es um Telegraphen ging und dann um Telefon und so, das hat er da sehr interessant nachgezeichnet, auch ähm
Absolut äh zu empfehlen. Das ist also eine
eine Koryphäe auf diesem Gebiet und ähm war, also es war natürlich ein,
Ein älterer Herr ähm der ähm auch äh,
unglaublich begeistert war von von dem Kongress, ja? Also ich war ähm habe dann mich ab und zu mal mit ihm unterhalten, weil ich ja als äh äh,
dadurch, dass ich ähm ja in die in einem Track quasi verantwortlich war, also in dem Thema Politik habe ich mich natürlich auch so ein bisschen äh
mich um seine um sein Wohlbefinden äh gekümmert und immer mal wieder, wenn ich ihn gesehen habe, so und wie geht's? Und hast du hier schon gesehen und kennst du überhaupt die Party Area? So kann er natürlich noch nicht,
mit riesigen Augen da rein und meinte so, was äh das war ja schon auch äh war echt äh sehr äh sehr cool. Ähm.
So, dann äh noch einen äh Vortrag, den ich auch sehr spannend fand, äh oder der äh von Jugend hackt.
Wo also die äh ein Projekt der Open Knowledge Foundation, die also für ähm die also äh ja Jugendliche und fast noch Kinder äh ebenso an,
anders arbeiten mit offenen Daten heranführen und mit denen irgendwie kleinere und größere äh Projekte machen. Da waren also vier äh absolut,
coole äh Jugendliche, die dann da so ihre ihre Projekte vorgestellt haben. Das war äh auch echt mal geil und glaube ich, lehrte so.
Einigen. Äh also das hat halt auch so ein so ein so gezeigt so, okay geil so, wir sind zwar
wir die die Lage ist ernst, aber wir haben halt echt ein paar äh wir haben halt echt auch coolen Nachwuchs, auf den wir zählen können. So, das war ähm hat mich auch
Das war sehr ähm erhellend und äh erfreulich.
Also sie hatten äh ich habe den noch nicht gesehen, also da waren die äh die Jugendlichen selber auf der Bühne dann sozusagen dabei beim Talk. Ah ja, sehr cool.
Sehen Sie hier unser Projekt und so haben wir jetzt supergeil.
Geilen Scheiß haben die gebaut. Das das ist auf jeden Fall auch äh ein sehr, sehr schöner Vortrag gewesen.
Ja und dann gab's natürlich noch so die die Klassiker, aber die braucht man ja gar nicht. Äh gar nicht, um unbedingt mehr zu erwähnen und ich glaube, alle anderen Vorträge äh ähm insbesondere aus dem Politikbereich hatten wir ja, glaube ich, auch schon in der letzten Sendung. Deswegen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr da wirklich alle hatten, aber wir können ja so in den nächsten äh Wochen auch nochmal das eine oder andere nach äh holen. Ich
wie gesagt, noch so ein bisschen hinterher, hab für mich erstmal so ein paar äh Standards ähm abgeklappert, hier das mit dem Trauerkeim Scan, den du nicht selbst gefälscht hast, äh.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge schon.
Nee, haben wir, das haben wir nicht angesprochen.
Haben wir nicht, bist du sicher?
Ja, siehst du, jetzt haben wir nämlich genau das Problem, deswegen wollte ich, dass die jetzt gerade beenden.
Welches Problem?
Dass wir nicht wissen, was wir erzählt haben und was nicht.
Achso, na gut, dafür haben wir ja unsere eigenen Shownotes, das äh ist immer ganz hilfreich, dass man nochmal nachschlagen kann, wovon man eigentlich äh drüber gesprochen hat
Mir war so, dass wir das irgendwie angesprochen haben, aber tatsächlich den Shownotes nach haben wir es nicht angesprochen, also spreche ich das nochmal an, ja? Ist auch so ein,
Der Vortrag gefiel mir auf mehreren Ebenen sehr gut. Ähm erstmal war es halt einfach mal wieder so ein schönes, ich habe da mal was rausgefunden und hier ist der Bericht Talk so, das das passt immer sehr gut auf den,
auf den Kongress finde ich.
Dann ähm war's halt auch einfach mal wirklich eine krasse Story. Also der kurze ist so äh es wurde da einfach so ein,
Bildkompressionsfehler in den äh industriellen Scannern von Xerox gefunden, die im Prinzip bedeuten das wahrscheinlich in den letzten acht Jahren einfach alle Scans, die diese Teile von Zahlen gemacht haben und einfach falsch sind.
Einfach alle. Ein richtiges, großes, mega Desaster. Aber vor allem äh,
Der Vortragen hat es einfach auch so lustig gemacht und und und so unterhaltsam äh diesen Talk rübergeschoben und da sieht man dann auch einfach schön diese Interaktion dann auch mit dem Publikum, wie alle irgendwie mitgehen und so und das äh ist also äh auf mehreren Ebenen
ein empfehlenswerter Talk.
Der hatte, also der hatte halt äh,
der David, der war so, also du siehst ja der besiegt sich ja auch selber, der die ganze Zeit bei dem Vortrag, weil er sich so freut, weil er auch merkt, dass das halt gerade abgeht und das,
auch rüber bringt und so, der hat dich ähm
Der war so begeistert, ähm als er die als sein Talk angenommen wurde und der hat dann auch glaube ich irgendwie so jeden Tag irgendwie mehrfach äh so getwittert, so oh geil Kongress und da ich ich werde dabei sein, ich freue mich so sehr, dass
Zwischendurch schon dachte so, oh fuck, so nicht dass der was was ist jetzt so, ne? Der ist ein bisschen zu euphorisch, ne? Nicht, dass der da irgendwie nachher ähm ähm mit der Zwangsjacke abgeholt werden muss, also weil der hat so,
der hatte halt so eine Euphorie, ja? Und äh ja, hat auch ähm,
ein ein Wahnsinnsfeedback zu dem Talk und das ist wirklich äh das ist auch wirklich toll. Vor allem wir erleben das gelingt, denen halt so zu halten, dass denen äh halt auch, dass ja wirklich für alle,
verständlich ist und also ist ein ist ein super Vortrag, super vorbereitet, mit Liebe gemacht und unglaublich gelungen, ja.
Ja und auch mit einer interessanten Reflexion. Das heißt, nicht nur sozusagen über das Ding selber gesprochen hat, sondern auch sehr viel darüber gesprochen hat, wie er das strategisch durchgezogen hat und warum irgendwie der eine Move jetzt äh besser oder schlechter gewesen wäre.
Also das ist ein absolutes Muss, innen gesehen zu haben. Das stimmt.
Weitere Vorträge werden wir dann demnächst nochmal nachschieben, wenn wir irgendwie alles im Blick haben.
Ja und wenn wenn es wenn es die Themen äh Gebieten. Ja.
Aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal Schluss machen, oder?
Wir müssen jetzt langsam zum Ende kommen. Da darf natürlich der Dank nicht fehlen,
Und zwar geht der Dank äh diese Woche an Hannes People Sven.
Und an eine unbekannte Person. Und zwar gibt es äh bei bei Amazon, glaube ich, das Problem, wenn vom,
Wunschzettel etwas bestellt wird, was nicht von Amazon geliefert wird, dann liegt dem eine äh Rechnung bei, als als hätte ich das bestellt.
Und ähm dann kann ich nicht sehen, von wem das ist,
Und wenn das passiert, dann äh ist das vielleicht gut, einfach mal kurz noch äh sich so bei mir zu melden, weil sonst kann ich nicht danken und das ist natürlich dann äh zu vermeiden und schade, wenn das geschieht.
Oder ich ich habe irgendwas bestellt und konnte mich nicht dran erinnern. Kann.
Das wollte ich doch schon immer haben.
Geil.
Gut, wir müssen Schluss machen, oder?
Ja, wir müssen, wir müssen, ich, ich muss.
Genau. Du musst, okay. Du musst wir müssen äh ihr alle müsst wieder einschalten. Das nächste Mal, wenn Doktor Netz Politik wieder auf den Tisch kommt. Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao, ciao.